oh god what is he doing how's it going
bros my name is pierre back and welcome
to adventure time time to angle I
suppose no I'll already mention time
everyone loves adventure time we play
the intro like it was only yesterday
they actually have the boys uyghurs it's
kind of cool so I play danger but I'll
play for your breasts cuz they have such
an amazing story
this watch holy [ __ ] whoa what's going
on over there better check it out so we
are ready
okay so I can dodge amazing dodging
capacities that's a word apparently I'll
tilt this way and then I'll tell it this
way
amazing which way this way what that
exploded
jump they're robots all right why are
they road blocks
why who put those there digging the the
music yeah yeah punch stuff I can fist
flame I will punch on your friends I
would punch on your parents have a bunch
of buns and your bun choke sir chickens
aren't surd they're ladies pardon me
hello you I'll be sick it looks pretty
evil time to bust it out
[Music]
dae-su per punch are you cereal
my jaw at my professor
brofist oh right in the junk nice oh
[ __ ] I got sucked in the junk that's
never a good thing
never dangerous awesome stuff sounds
dangerous and awesome
oh I'm inside a whale hopefully that's
supposed to select collect six Gunther
amazing koonta oh where am I now
ah the bubblegum Kingdom good time what
are you doing good touch that's nice
not any more night hello how they
explode why are you fighting me we're
supposed to be friends right
another Guinta thank you another Kunta
thank you he says yes I say no hug me
never aah
Kunta we got all the guns our quest
complete an amazing oh nice so that's
what we go inside Jesus that is an ace
how did that boat get in here how did
the trees get in here what are the disco
teddy bears doing here got a live disco
teddy bears I don't have to punch them
but I feel like I should all right stick
scar friend what are you doing why where
I'll explain later
I don't even know what you're gonna
explain tonight still punch I can use
faint Jake's girlfriend to punch that
deal that's amazing ha ha I want to
punch them I want to punch them all it's
not nice stop telling me what's nice
don't fart
mendl's
she's taking on Jake there we go oh my
god we have to let you there shorts [ __ ]
yeah
what did we do with it there we go
mmm had this guy better be ugly hold me
cuz they got chicks huh nice haircut
dude that is beautiful and cut yeah oh
my god that is actually badass oh god oh
god what do I do punch his face yes
that's right chainsaw man oh God
Kelly's face sorry you're ugly and will
make a difference honestly punch all the
buns even though it's buns is not their
punches buns in case it was his face
Oh God Oh God wrong side yeah oh my god
I am the worst player in the world so
like how did you put those chainsaws
there or didn't do you have to refill
them with gas every once in a while like
I don't understand how does that work
what do I do
fleiss's belly what do i do what do I do
I don't know what to do the arrow says
click Oh nobody got more life what did I
miss
now I have to charge it I have to charge
it cha cha cha cha cha check my bra fat
max mofo you [ __ ]
alright I got you now charging my
brofist sword up the bellies and a chop
yes Josh [ __ ] gasp yeah you got some
awesome fat damage with that kite your
face has never been cooler oh stop it no
no no ho ho you fool huh oh I was just
punching you because you're an evil dude
what's the props
[Music]
I'm not a bad guy the time totem you
sure you look pretty you look pretty
evil Thanks
in fact I'm the living embodiment of all
heroic deeds and oh yeah I still think
you're evil I'm not so bad I can do it
oh my god I knew we couldn't trust you
can I punch this bear yes I can amazing
he's so fat
gotta get those sandwiches I'm good
sandwich your face and make it explode a
bond to baguio what did the chicken say
while they cross the road
come on ketchup and let's go wait white
okay this game really promotes violence
against poor animals like you really
punch everything that's cute and fluffy
Oh
Lemongrab all right we need to fight him
huh
yes what is he doing why is he Oh God
oh my god secret boobs
what is that acid oh no I wouldn't
understand try me
oh god those are ugly lemon atrocities
punch that vine punch that bride she
likes it look at him he loves it
Oh God
my bet is his urine honestly there we go
punch that punch
yeah brofist his ass brofist that lock
amazing oh my god alright we got power
Jews chickens spread a food bag Eliza's
Oh powered let's do that so all my
punches are supercharged but I don't
want to punch you Jake yeah my friend
high-five
yeah yeah alright punch that chicken
holy [ __ ] poor chicken oh my god oh my
god what is going on
calm down Finn it's just a game Oh God
for beer
sorry beer okay so sorry so sorry lamp
princess what are you doing here man she
looks extra lump in this game it kind of
turns me on in awkward way what am I
doing with her I just love how she has a
boy voice but she's still a girl and
she's kind of ugly what is happening I
just left her I'm black [ __ ] that I
guess let's try the lump attack I don't
know what it does Hey
best attack ever there it is
the legendary swordfish amazing for fish
my god
all right time to knock this guy out of
the park
another bass no problem I have my
swordfish what do i do oh my god what do
I do
okay am I supposed to punch this oh god
help me
one more baby no I jumped too early
oh my god oh my god that's annoying as
hell Finn really has a saggy ass I got
it I gotta say it's very saggy I don't
know what Princess Bubblegum would say
my thing
I swear to God if I die at this boss
again mine gah
what no oh my god please for the love of
God and all holy I swear if I die again
I will motorboat fins ass I'm not even
joking come on oh come on baby we can do
and rest I believe at you oh god what is
he doing one more one more one more
I'm a charge and my top hat that's by
Josh
tickle that belly oh he tickled good son
he tickles
good
[Music]
[Applause]
so dad was adventure time time tangle
amazing let's book Galilee oh my god we
gotta choose I never knew his name he
only dresses in the highest fashion this
goose loves to rhyme I love this font
they use this it's like an improved not
so obnoxious comic science love it
anyway thank you thank you boys for
watching this episode and hanging out
with me today thank you for liking on
this video and that was zebras in the
next one as always stay on row fish